foreign
[Music]
chances are when you were a kid when you
watched the Star Wars prequels you
walked out of that film wanting to spin
the sword like a Jedi now perhaps it's
not the most practical way of fighting
it sure looks cool and that is why
Disney has sold millions of these little
toys but there's one problem chances are
when you spin a sword you look like me
and that is to say a complete door now
how did he get the actress to look like
they know what they're doing well they
have experts come in to teach them and
it occurred to us that we happen to know
an expert of the blade as well Luke
LaFontaine an expert on the history of
Swords choreography fight designer stunt
man so Luke is going to take us to the
park where he's going to show us the
elegant art of spinning a sword and
hopefully by the end of this video you
and I maybe can look a little less dorky
[Music]
so we should just do one thing here I'm
gonna put this sword back that's how you
store them I guess
I don't know how many times I told you
don't do this with the swords but it's
okay but but it looks cool Luke point
taken that's what today's gonna be about
doing cool looking stuff with swords and
by the end of the day I swear to God
you're gonna be able to spin swords and
look like a badass I promise awesome so
my dreams of doing a Star Wars prequel
fan film of the utmost degree can maybe
come true after this do you ever notice
when these guys all swing really hard
and they make these power swings the
blades made out of light it doesn't
weigh anything why would you have to
swing it hard
yeah
I like you that much I'll do it for you
Nico we're joined by Jake everyone
joined by Jordan I think we should uh
invite you guys to join us for a little
cringe Fest here and let's watch each
one of us take a turn spinning a sword
and showing our current abilities Jordan
take it away
oh I have a lightsaber so imagine
it turns on
don't make the noises Jordan it's like
saying pew when you pull the trigger
that was good that was good good job
there you go all right I guess I'm the
one clapping all right good job Jake
you're next I've worked with Luke as a
stunt person with a blade in the Shadow
of Mordor video that we did many years
ago that was honestly one of the only
times I ever stun performed or did
anything with the blade so other than my
own self-taught training I don't know
what I'm doing hold on
oh there it is
oh
man I can hear I can hear Luke holding
his breath no hey I said today was about
fun he he unabashedly just went for it
and that's what we're supposed to do you
didn't smack yourself so you passed
thank you listen Seas get to grease okay
all right Nico let's see what you got
I'll just actually spit in my sword you
know
casually
that's all I know that's it that's
that's all I got that's where I just
awkwardly walkable
I'm gonna clean you guys in now if I do
this
the problem's not the swords the problem
is my physical lack of confidence that's
50 of the job is no matter what you do
you do it with confidence all right guys
we're gonna go through this I want you
to come over here and line up with me
and we can all do this together put your
right foot forward left foot back swords
out from here you're gonna just let the
tip drop and come up and over
there you go that is what's called a
mulane or a mulanello the most iconic
sword spin that is in every movie it's
an outline pairing so if someone's
cutting at me from this side this might
take too long
but if I can sweep them out of the way
and return the cut that's all one motion
but it also happens to be a sword spin
let's do the exact same thing in Reverse
you're going to use your wrist and pull
the sword in the other direction let it
come underneath now you notice we're all
kind of close proximity you didn't smack
me I didn't smack you nobody hit anybody
else mission accomplished
next thing we're going to do is troll a
sword on the inside of the body the
sword tip drops the arm rotates over and
swings on the inside watch my wrist in
my hand
is what you don't want to do
don't throw a bunch of funky things with
your hand let the sword do the work just
drop the tip and let it roll over that's
it now let's incorporate those two
things together and do one twirl on the
outside one twirl on the inside and go
outside inside let's try to do the same
thing in Reverse you're going to go here
and here so if I've got a sword blade
watch one two you can easily cut someone
and cut someone and come back so if I
cut you this way or I cut you that way
I'm still using the sword let's add one
more move in actually it's two more
moves because it's going to build into
one of the major sword spins I'm going
to teach you let the sword drop behind
you on the second turn rotate your body
now lift up
go up
and come back to Center
one two three four
now how did your bones not twist into a
map so what I'm seeing here is it looks
like you can actually just keep doing
that sequence as one long unbroken Loop
is that possible yes you can because you
just go back to one and repeat the
pattern so from here I can just keep
doing this all day long oh there it is
there it is that's this is what I'm
looking for this is why we're here what
Luke was just doing that was it that was
the moment I could feel the magic I
could feel the thrill I hope I get to do
that by the end of the day there's no
hope you're gonna do yes that was like a
really bad bastardization of Yoda okay
[Music]
mastering the art of the blade is one of
the most difficult things to do it takes
years but you know it's not difficult
making a website on Squarespace
which is today's sponsor Squarespace is
an all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online to say you want to start a dojo
well you're going to need a website for
that Dojo that's why you should go to
Squarespace because they have
award-winning templates that let you
customize exactly how you want your dojo
to be presented to your customers now
that you have a website for your dojo
now you're going to want to sell some
merch so whatever you decide to sell
Squarespace makes it super easy design
your products and production inventory
and shipping are handled for you saving
you time money and effort so now you're
selling merch congratulations but say
now you want to sell exclusive content
I'm a sword expert and I like to put up
tutorials on how to spin swords well
with member areas I can offer exclusive
access to these tutorials
if you're like me and you're serious
about spreading awareness about your
dojo take a stab at making a website
with Squarespace and to help you get
started you can get 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or a domain if you
head to squarespace.com Corridor crew so
now we're gonna head back to the park
and learn how to spin these swords
the sword spin that I'm teaching you the
derivations of it are Chinese
traditionally Chinese swordsmanship the
sword was almost always kept in motion
there was an idea on the battlefield
that if I had made myself into a
whirling dervish of blades I can pretty
much go through 10 or 12 guys somebody's
gonna get hit because you're basically a
walking Cuisinart
on a European sword when you do all
these same movements you have to take
into account the guard so when I come
here the guard has to stay on the
outside of my wrist otherwise I'll hit
myself if this is not what the sword was
designed to do
we're designed to catch sword blades and
shove them off and hack somebody to
death with a sword I'm not doing
something historical so relax imagine
this is Willow and I'm a much older mad
Mart again
check this out left-handed
oh
[Music]
yeah you guys are all screwed because
you're doing so well now I'm probably
going to wind up forcing you to do this
with two swords
okay now I get to make it harder let's
make it harder what we need to do is
make this repeat right so if we need to
make this repeat you're going back
through the same Loop so where you start
is where you end up so if I don't stop
[Music]
just got to try he's gotten a loop when
you break him out of the loop the basis
for doing sword spins is the natural
flow of the sword the momentum and
learning how to control it that's what
we're going to work on right now so
let's let's split up go practice and see
what we can get to
I'm gonna try to learn something I don't
know I'm gonna try to make it slow
process understand try again
like just being able to let it like
you know
instead of me like
that's what I'm doing it's a lot of
wrist and fingers watch my wrists and
fingers here here look at how Loosely
I'm gripping the sword it's crazy when
you start doing something you start
realizing why the technique is so
important and when people train for
hours and hours it's like just training
your forearms and your wrists to be
loose I have no idea what I'm doing and
I mask that with a giggle
it's hard for me to just jump into
something like a zero preparation and
have confidence how do I not look like a
[__] or a guy who watches way too much
anime which I promise you I'm not
this this this this okay I'm in it I'm
doing things
now what like I just did a twirl and
like that's the extent of my knowledge
how do I exit that without feeling like
a goofball right that's good that's good
now stop right here don't lift your arms
so high let this be a cut now go back
into the pattern bring your hand over
that's it
won't turn now yep yes
I got it good makes sense good good when
we first started producing short films
and videos one great way to save money
on the production was just to put
yourself in the production whether it
was a bad guy or you know a faceless
villain or an orc and I remember that
Spite specifically and my job was to
come in and go what got one and then get
hit and then to come in and go ah two
and then to come in again like this and
get stabbed and I other than that I just
had to do it at the right time three
days of choreography and only four
swings that ended up on camera and but
today I get to do all the sword swing
and I won't see I basically that's how
I'm doing it in my head there's four
people to kill one
so if you guys saw to the deck I was
kind of just watching in the background
it's kind of left unset if I decide to
join the school or not but in my head I
decide to join the school I think if I
train really hard I can do it I've
always wanted to be good with weapons
swords are hard though this is might be
one of like the hardest weapons you can
learn and to look good with on film so I
don't know we'll see what Luke thinks
okay guys come over here come to me
because
um you've all been working on this
you're all doing an awesome job let's
have everybody go individually and the
difference now is remember what I talked
about in terms of commitment if you're
on a Mountaintop in a kung fu movie and
you did this badass sword Spin and the
sun was Rising behind you
you can't suddenly go oh I screwed it up
sell it to me so who wants to go first
I'll go first see Nico's Brave cool I
love it come on let's go I believe in
you here we go
[Music]
see see the difference it's okay because
you're laughing now because we're done
that's the first time that you've ever
done something like all the way through
and stayed stoic Luke gave me confidence
he gave me confidence to believe myself
and to also spin a sword correctly you
did awesome Jordan you're up all right
here we go have fun I'm gonna fight my
opponent in my head there are four men I
need to kill
[Music]
yeah look at that
got him
ready to go nice
brilliant thank you good job all right
you have Jake no you're taking been
training with like an extra difficult
sword here right yes you're having
troubles with it earlier yes well I hope
it worked out for you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jake gets brownie points for like doing
a whole scene oh it's almost six times
and didn't hit yourself once you get a
diploma okay remember when I said
something about doing this with two
swords Jake did this with his right and
then his left hand so that means both
sides of his brain are working and I
want to see if I can force Jake to do
this pattern with two swords
let's go gym Flying Too Close to the sun
I've got two swords I can do this
pattern with my right hand I can do this
pattern with my left hand if we
simultaneously mix them together you go
one two pull back over now you put it
together
what each hand is doing separately
because you know that you can do it in
your right and your left it's about the
flow
because it's a symmetrical pattern
[Music]
don't bring it over bring
it bring it up freaking my left hand is
like
just make a little circle behind your
back
there it is now do that with both hands
damn it
oh you are doing it actually
he's just not being dude come on Jake
when you you almost hit the loop
swirl them twirl them oh he's so
oh my God
he did it he got a phone he technically
did it look you technically did it for
one entire rotation you did the entire
pattern Jake gets a lollipop and an ice
cream sandwich yes
all you guys you did awesome that
pattern that I taught you would take
days it would take days to perfect it
and then do it in one hand and then even
up to doing it in two hands weeks months
years you guys learned how to do this
you didn't clunk yourselves you didn't
drop the sword you didn't whack yourself
in the eye pass pass
you know thanks again Luke for teaching
us these valuable skills but the thing
is there's like a Vista overlooking like
downtown Los Angeles right there so I
just need to like put on some retrowave
and go show the world what we've learned
do it man it's your dream
thank you
[Music]
foreign